several state dealer associations have
basically declared war on Tesla that
issue whether automakers have to go
through dealers to sell their vehicles
you can go and look at a showroom but
you can't ask questions about pricing
and you can't order one there are you
kidding me
it is my honor to welcome to the stage
mr. Elon Musk
when Elon Musk launched the first Tesla
sports car he didn't just set out to
create a mass market for electric
vehicles he wanted to disrupt the entire
auto industry by cutting out the
middleman and selling his cars directly
to consumers no hard sell no Commission
for employees and uniform prices at
every store Tesla sales approach has
resonated with customers who want a more
interactive car buying experience I went
to the gallery in Houston and Saten one
and immediately said I have to have this
car mat home is one of those Tesla
converts he's a realtor in Austin Texas
who spends a lot of time on the road
driving clients and his sleek model s he
loves the fact that his car doesn't
require much maintenance and can be
charged overnight in his own garage but
when Matt went to purchase his Tesla he
couldn't just walk into a store and buy
one I actually had to go online
configure it and order it sight unseen
and then have it shipped out from
California on a third party truck have
it delivered to a third party location I
mean it was like I was a spy or
something getting some James Bond car
delivers unlike the big car companies
Tesla doesn't have a network of
independent dealerships that sell its
cars the company runs its own showrooms
but in Texas along with five other
states the government makes it illegal
to walk into a Tesla store and buy a car
and makes no sense
that an American manufactured vehicle
would be so challenging to get you'd
have to jump through so many hoops
almost every state has some sort of
restriction on purchasing cars directly
from manufacturers the purpose of these
laws which date back to the 1930s is to
prevent car buyers from cutting out the
middlemen which make up a big political
constituency the Lone Star State has
about 1,300 car dealerships employing a
hundred thousand people you should
embrace the franchise dealer network
the best most efficient and most
pro-consumer way of selling new cars and
trucks but if car buyers really
preferred going through third-party
dealers why do they need government
protection companies have been trying to
sell straight to consumers for a long
time in the late 90s Ford attempted to
circumvent the dealerships in Texas by
starting its own stores the state hit it
with a 1.7 million dollar fine and the
following year then Governor george w
bush signed a law strengthening
protections for the dealership cartel
now Elon Musk is taking his own shot at
selling direct to customers in the past
five years Tesla has spent over 1.2
million dollars on Texas lobbyists in an
effort to eliminate the direct sales ban
it's not a free-market approach and so
what my bill basically says is that a
manufacturer of an automobile can sell
direct to the consumer if they want to
Republican state legislator Jason Isaac
introduced a bill in 2017 that would
eliminate car dealership rules he's come
up against the politically connected
Texas auto dealers association all he
wants is an exception to a good law that
searched Texas and Texans and what it
does is establishes a monopoly for him
and eliminates his competition and the
auto lobby dealership is very effective
at working the political system to their
benefit that's not necessarily
pro-business but pro auto dealership
business alone lawmakers didn't act on
Isaac's bill this session making it the
third time that Tesla's efforts have
been blocked in Texas customers like
home are left to make their own
arrangements to purchase Tesla's out of
state but Elon Musk campaign to remake
the car industry is a hint of what's to
come
even Apple which pulled off one of the
greatest retail success stories of the
last 20 years by opening its own network
of stores is working on its own car a
Silicon Valley succeeds in its quest to
take over this nearly trillion dollar
industry the dealership model may not
last
I think the consumers are gonna start to
demand this more and more as they
realize wait there's an autonomous
vehicle coming in I can't buy it that
why is that
well because that autonomous vehicle
company doesn't have a dealer network
we've got to find some free market
solutions that allow those companies to
sell direct to their consumers it's a
better vehicle period and having that
seamless manufacturer purchasing the
financing options and then the service I
think goes a long way to making it
easier for the consumer and beneficial
really for overall pricing
[Music]